Here is that formula written out in Java. Have a close look at the parenthesis.
I was very careful to compute the entire expression, then have parenthesis
around it, and only then take the integer part of the final answer. Now we are
almost home free. The red tiles was the same as the pairs and the y tiles as
the pairs plus one. Here I'm running the program and when I supply the same
inputs as in the example problem, a 100 inches for the width. Tile size of 5,
then I get the expected answer. Now the important part of this entire exercise
is to first do it by hand. If you can't do it by hand, you can't program it.
And doing it by hand gives you valuable intuition that you need to write the
Java code. You'll get to practice this with another example that Sarah will
show you.